Let's get right into some notable discussions
from The David Pakman Show Subrata. You can join
more than thirty two thousand of our viewers
and listeners on the sub Reddit, David Pakman,
Dotcom, Reddit. Join the discussion and a lot of
important things being discussed there. Here is a
question that has been coming up a lot. And there
was a very interesting discussion and poll of our
audience. The question is, do you guys have any
sympathy for anti AXA's who wind up getting sick
with covid-19? And we're going to look at such
a story in a moment. And the the majority in
our audience said no, but I don't wish death on
anybody or no, they should have known better. So
a lot of not feeling any sympathy for people
who don't get vaccinated and later get sick.
Some in the audience said, I have a little bit
of sympathy, but not much. And by far the least
common answer among our audience was, yes, I do
have sympathy for the anti boxers who get sick,
and I hope they all have a speedy recovery.
I'm sort of in that minority and I understand
that there is a significant level of ignorance
and disconnection from reality in many of these
people. But I do consider themselves victims and
I know the AGYEMAN will call in and say, David,
you're too empathetic. That's not going to
get you anywhere. Maybe that's the case.
But I think that I mean, listen, I think it's
totally normal to resent the anti boxers. There
is no doubt about it. They're extending this.
We have widespread vaccines available here
and they're choosing not to get
one. And this furthers the spread
and it increases death and it increases
hospitalization. I get it. So I understand
resenting. But also when I hear that someone like,
for example, pro Trump anti VAX radio hosts Phil
Valentine is now on a ventilator, which we
will talk about in a moment. I don't I don't
feel good about it. It doesn't make me I don't
like that. So that's the point of view, I guess,
of the audience. Another post from the sub Reddit
called Clearing Up the arguments over mask wearing
brings up a couple of interesting questions.
And it says now that the CDC is recommending
indoor mask wearing again, even for vaccinated
Americans. I'm already seeing the insane outrage
and ignorance from conservatives we saw last year.
I thought this would be a good subrata it to make
sense of the issue because they feel like I'm
losing my mind. So I'm just clearing this up.
Feel free to discuss. There's plenty of evidence
to show that the vaccinated covid patients do not
end up in the hospital. In fact, they experience
very little symptoms. This is like the flu shot,
right? I remember the one year I didn't get the
flu shot. I got the flu. I was bedridden for a
week. I got the flu this last year with a flu
shot, had a minor headache and sniffles this
is the way to debunk any argument stating
the vaccines don't work. See, we told you
then you have the mask wearing. Why would I
wear a mask if I'm if I'm vaccinated? Well,
because you can still transmit it to the
unvaccinated. We might have some people say
they don't care about giving it to unvaccinated
people, which honestly, I find perfectly OK.
But that's the reason the CDC is recommending
masks. Right. Lastly, why do these conservatives
think mask wearing is about government control?
I don't get it. Biden hasn't taken advantage
of government control at all. That's what
they always said. It's a slippery slope.
No, they're just going to want you to wear a mask
because we haven't. One hundred percent defeated
this thing, right? It's insane to me how little
I can empathize with their views right now,
unless I'm the crazy one, which is what I'd like
you all to help me with, because to me, these
people must be very, very stupid and lack any
critical thinking skills. How is it possible to
reason with them how you can't? And so the pretzel
that you find yourself in trying to talk to these
people and saying, how can I just get them to get
it? Why don't they understand it? Unfortunately,
we can both feel sympathy and empathy for people
who get sick and resent them and be going out of
our minds because any conversation with them
is an exercise in futility and frustration and
desperation. It's all of the above. And, you know,
there's this concept from I don't know if it's
I don't know if I don't know what area of
psychotherapy it's from, but it's basically
being able to hold to conflicting ideas at the
same time. Right. You know, in a relationship,
it might be that you find yourself incredibly
angry at someone who hasn't treated you right.
But yet you still love them because they're family
or whatever the case may be. And you've got to
kind of hold both ideas. It's the same thing here.
And the word empathy keeps coming up. We can both
empathize and sympathize with people who are
getting sick without being vaccinated and be mad,
resentful and frustrated up to the wazoo because
of those very same people. I think it makes
absolutely perfect sense. Joined the discussion.
Weigh in yourself at David Pakman Dotcom. Read it.